there was a fight we all wanted a couple
years ago yeah Jon Jones yeah is that
still possible now that he's gone up
it's not even that's like it's kind of
like the Alex thing where everyone's
like oh we need a fifth fight and
everyone's like everyone else is more
bricked up for that than me and him I'm
not interested in fifth fight with Alex
that's exactly unless he comes up and
gets another belt that's that's exactly
right most people are like look everyone
are three one you're gonna make it oh
it's 1-1 in MMA you got to do a third
one and I was like no one cares no my
thing is me and John's the same thing
even like on impulsive when they said
what they said I was like I thought it
was a joke and then he actually pull it
up and I was like Ah that's funny but
it's what it wait what happened with
just Giants gave him you know props I
guess from a martial arts perspective I
guess he said you know
he was asked the question like who are
you a fan of and he was like well
actually like I'm a fan of Israel oh oh
fire bro that's the thing it's like fire
if there's
promoting a fight and there's another
thing which is martial arts right there
is fighting that's absolutely like what
you know we were saying earlier about
like that when when they two guys part
each other but then they become you know
yeah yeah connection
um
ha
hahaha
so Izzy's an aliens
[Music]
let's go slowly again
hey
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that it does I remember in Puerto Rico
that's a great story
[Laughter]
about a week ago okay let's go you
remember Puerto Rico Ash was never there
he's not a part of the story at all
one time
[Music]
okay
do you know what's funny
we believe we won a worldwide [__]
platform
and yeah
[Laughter]
the videographer who feels every moment
in your life
hey cut the cameras
as he said Jeff knows when to film
[Music]
75th Street and 63rd on [__] 20th
it's like what the it's all just like I
don't get it I know
how long did you live in China and you
still couldn't figure out [__] math
she said he aced the women not the test
good boy
no Nigeria
it's like oh it's like everyone's on a
race to Nowhere yeah legit India yeah
yeah yeah
Ghana is really coming up is Nigeria a
little jealous that Ghana's coming up I
lived okay I lived in Ghana for about a
year and a half oh really Accra
if you know you know like I went to
Sunnyside primary school I was out there
in Ghana I tried to watch at the bank
all that we ain't jealous also jollof
rice came from Nigeria
talk that [__] talk that [__] but who
got the best but just be honest
Nigerians
Puerto Rican
house
three countries
jollof rice with this guy I'm talking
about dogs
Dick I feel how they want to feel what
I'm saying it's Ghana Nigeria and then
there's one more who has the Joe Loft
there's fire what is it uh no no start
to the next Sudan no Senegal Senegal yes
everybody said Senegal got the best yeah
everybody
in Canada I'm just saying
I was like yo guys
no one Nigeria got the best yo what's
that little chicken dish they got in
Nigeria the uh the chicken skewer thing
or whatever
so yeah no no it's not chicken it's
normally goat meat or beef Jeff knows
it's like hey you are what you eat
oh [__] let's go G's up dog
is the best food that's my favorite food
on the planet because also I've had it
in America the best part would you eat
the goat bro yeah you just got it right
now
Christmas
[Applause]
yeah but this is nice put that on your
thumb
we talk about watches
where's Blood Diamond when you need them
bro I am the captain now look at me yo
that's beautiful it caught my eye it
just caught my eyes like oh [__]
African dudes
that's why
with them
I connect you with David people yeah
but that's Factory bezel
and is he and he's bought one for his
dad too exactly the same that's what I
like about it respect it's good respect
my mom's birthday was on June 10th which
was on Saturday Sunday
well you were saying Factory bezel and
he said he got it for his dad and all of
a sudden you were like oh respect yeah
so Factory bezel means it retains the
value Rolex put the diamonds in it yeah
exactly dude on 47th Street exactly yeah
yeah so I bought one for my dad but some
dude on 47th Street put the diamonds on
it
I've chosen Beverly Hills or whatever
sentiment so me and my dad now we're
like twins my mom's birthday was on
Saturday what'd you get it I'm gonna get
a Rolex dude she doesn't know yet
oh yeah I don't know break your news
breaking news
what does she want what one is because I
know she's going to be picky after
watching her yeah
she's striking less than acceptable or
whatever you need to get us the best no
I'll get a meme we'll be triplets I'll
be honest your parents seem like they're
they're very difficult to impress when
when did you feel the first time you
impressed them like ah you know what's
funny bro that dancing video they
reacted yeah they were like they were
like funny yeah
good at dancing no no then but before
that when I started well Talent Quest
when I pulled up to the counter Quest
when um the video you guys saw
one of my um I think Deputy principals
or Deans
he like he was like have you ever seen
him dance before and they're like
no we haven't and it's like oh you're
going to be impressed
and I literally and then they saw me did
what I did they were happiest whatever
but
if you're not a doctor accountant lawyer
engineer you're a what a failure but
dancing and press the [__] out of them
yeah
no no now it does they appreciate it now
that's interesting that like like
because Akash I imagine you've gone
through the same thing and like Indian
culture has this very similar to
Nigerian culture where this is this
pressure for Success yeah but there is
this like appreciation of the Arts like
if you're nice at dancing there's like
we're singing but mainly for us only the
Indian stuff if you dance American
they're gonna be like I don't even
understand but still if you're a great
singer if you're a great dancer it's a
huge but be honestly how big Bollywood
even in Nigeria in Africa that's huge
bro I don't know if you know
no so we're not Bollywood movies on
Sundays was the thing after church we'll
go home and watch it on TV or also had
the VHS since I used to watch but one of
my favorite movies as a kid was a movie
called
[Laughter]
the real real Indian yeah that's what
God that's what God sounds like yeah
yeah but like yeah was my favorite
movies it was a sword fighting movie
whatever but like yeah that was part of
the culture and that was something that
like as a kid I remember used to watch
the VHS over and over I should probably
watch it again as an adult because your
life is a Bollywood movie bro yeah
that you [__] with that you'd like to
meet
[Music]
[Laughter]
whatever
all right calm down
[Laughter]
it's just a sick
hello
please that's a waste for you that's a
waste for you